The first thing to realize when
designing your application architecture,
is that your phone typically has
a much more powerful processor, and
a much larger battery
than your wearable.
You want to offload as much as
possible away from the wearable
to try to get the most
battery life out of it.
Another key part of the application
architecture is that the phone
has direct access to the Internet,
while the wearable over here does not.
So let's imagine a scenario where you'll
building an app to show weather updates
on a wearable.
The phone will need to make
the request to fetch the data,
and then send that to
the wearable via data relay API.
There are many ways you
can implement this, but
if you do not design this
carefully it may perform poorly.
So how do we implement
an efficient solution to this?
One of the first improvements comes
from changing how you wake up
the wearable device.
Rather then having the wearable
wake up every 10 seconds or so,
and request an update of
information from the phone,
instead allow the phone to drive
updates to the wearable device.
The simple action of keeping
the watch asleep as long as possible
will help conserve battery life.
So once you've made the weather update
request from the phone to the internet,
you may get back outdated information.
An important step to do here is
to compare this with the previous
information downloaded earlier.
If there's no change to the information,
you should not update the watch.
There's no point waking it up just
to tell it that nothing has changed.
We want the watch sleeping
as much as possible.
If you have detected a change,
it's important to minimize the amount of
data we actually send to the wearable.
It would be a bad idea to send
the entire weather query result to
the wearable, since it probably
includes a lot of extra information,
such as what you see here.
Instead, we should pass
it on the phone and
send just a single temperature value,
like this one here, to the wearable.
Remember, we're trying to minimize the
amount of work done on the wearable, and
even things that might seem
trivial will add up eventually.
So how should we send
data to the wearable?
If you had to send a large
amount of temperature data for
a time range, it might be tempting
to create separate data items for
each time and temperature and
send them separately.
However for each piece of data,
set between the phone and
the wearable, there are overheads
added by the platform and the network.
These overheads include headers for
packets, acknowledgments per packet, and
energy required for every packet sent.
As well as activating
the wireless hardware.
When designing code to
send out over a network,
taking these overheads into
consideration is important.
So by storing many numeric values into
a single message, there'll be much less
data sent and processed,
than sending each one separately.
The results can be quite considerable,
as you can see here.
Once you've sent the item to the
wearable, you might be tempted to add
an acknowledgement to
check it was received.
However, if you're using data items,
they are guaranteed by
the framework to be synchronized
when the wearable is paired up, so
you can be sure they'll
eventually be received.
If you're using messages, then you will
need to check that they were received,
since transmission is never guaranteed
if the device is disconnected, or
something else happens.